let me pull up this tweet here and we'll
just we'll spend some time ragging on dr
fauci you know he's leaving
and i'm quite disappointed because this
means i won't be able to do the voice
rolls for freedom tunes anymore but uh
the truth is sheamus hasn't been calling
that's right sheamus of freedom toons he
hasn't called me to do a voice of fouchy
even with the big fouchy news i get it
sheamus
but i know what you're here for
ian miles chong tweeted fauci has the
fouchy devotional candle on his
bookshelves you couldn't make this up
here's a picture of fauci here's the
bookshelf behind him and right here you
can see it that's the fouchy devotional
candle it is an image of fouchy as like
i think jesus is that it let me see yeah
that's what those devotional candles are
they're usually for the virgin mary
in south america
all right fouchy out of the virgin has a
devotional candle of himself depicting
himself as as jesus is that what it is
of the savior of the savior
i
how many would you buy
no just one i don't know would you light
it
yeah
i said this yesterday but like i kept
saying he didn't want to retire because
out of vanity like he retiring means
that you're old and that you're like you
can no longer work and that's why his
announcement is very much like you know
i'm just stepping down to continue to
work even though he's like 81. i you
know maybe someone got this candle for
him as like a gag gift they were like
this is so funny or a candle i could
definitely see doing that to someone i
know if they were suddenly turned into a
devotional candle but to know that
you're going to have it in the
background of your interview to me it's
just like
isn't this this is this is a form of
narcissism right you see yourself as a
savior and incompetence i think it's
like nice mix between the two because
you're a doctor but have uh
you know no ability to discern science
from political science yeah i think
you're
an absolute clown so that's perfect i
think it was like it's a stereotype for
doctors right to have a god complex and
like the entire american media handed
this to vouching we're like no we really
could not make it through this pandemic
without you sir and i think it's gone to
his head so here check check this out
ian miles chong posted the photo
this is what's behind them is that
who is the suppose i was fouchy i would
definitely put that behind me yeah
that's hilarious i wouldn't buy it i
don't think but if people shifted to you
yeah people sent me stuff to our p.o box
for a while and one was a shirt with my
face on it i've worn it on the show i
think it's freaking hilarious one of my
favorite shirts i would i didn't go out
and make it to show everyone like hey
look how great i am but i'm sure people
are sending him tons of stuff uh
merchandise about him and he's just like
rolling with it if anyone made him a
devotional candle i would buy it and
bring it to you
i pointed this out because you know
before the show we were ragging on it
and then i was like to be fair someone
sent a golden bust of my face to us and
it's like sitting on a table downstairs
and i'm like
i
i don't know i like it came in a box
someone else opened the box someone else
put it there and now there's like this
bronze statue of me and it's like weird
i had a head shot that we used for um uh
one of our cass castle uh shows and it
was out in the living room for like a
month it was just on the table and i was
like yeah everyone get a taste like feel
it for like three weeks and then it
started to feel really weird so i took
it and put it in my closet you hung it
up in your room yeah i put it behind
some things in a on a shelf are you
talking about the painting no i want to
display that that thing's hot no it's
just a head shot from uh my college days
from like my los angeles uh ian has a
miniature version of himself on the
table right now yeah so this is another
example of it this is right here this is
ian crossland bobblehead someone made
thank you so much i didn't make it but
someone sent it to me and it would
almost be like an insult not to display
it at that point see that's that's the
thing right i remember when uh the the
photo went viral of fouchy in his office
and he's got a painting of himself
and then everybody was like he's got he
works under a painting of himself and
then we had someone on the show and they
were just like his daughter probably
painted it for him and then i was like
oh that's a good point
see that's why he would put it up with
the candle it totally could just be a
gift right someone was like this is
hilarious i will get this for you but
i don't know i guess he has just like
really lost my uh respect and any of my
you respected him no i never respect he
never earned my respect i guess what i
should say uh it's hard really not to
see this as
him like it's hard to imagine that he
doesn't look at that every day and think
like i am really saving america you know
what i mean like did you see them like
the long flowing hairs right you guys
would laugh at yourself with your busts
and your t-shirts and like you're humble
so there's there's an element to it but
like i don't know if that's how fat she
views this candle did you see the video
clip of him i did a i did a great
twitter troll he was quoted as saying
that he was like inspiring people it was
the fouchy effect and that he in this
time of of untruth he represented truth
and science something like that yeah so
i quoted it directly
and then under the tweet was like oops
can't forget the video and then i was
like we're gonna separate the men from
the boys here and see who actually read
the twitter thread and understood it was
a quote or who just blindly was like i
can't believe tim will say this about
himself but then jack pasok was on that
night and he was like oh i didn't click
through oh the video like he totally got
it afterwards but oh i didn't know jack
fell for it one of the boys i mean
that's what i wrote i'm saying somebody
can clip it i guess but uh yeah i
remember you doing that i mean i just
think that like anthony fauci is
an arrogant person and so if it were
someone who had humility i would laugh
this candle but it is like hard not to
be like come on guy you couldn't clear
your bookshelf at all i i i'm tasked
with saving people's lives and he's a
bit of a megalomaniac i think at the
very least that's safe it goes without
saying a bit of one the way he talks
about himself as a savior is a little
crazy look look at these photos okay
this guy abhi cole he's got the
devotional fouchy candle this guy this
lady julie pfeiffer she's got one here's
another fouchy a devotional candle with
a mask next to it and like
it's freaking insane too
if there is anything that makes me want
to just
buy a van and go live down by the river
and never think of any of this political
stuff again it is this
these people are serious guess what they
vote
yeah well i've seen these devotional
candles for like snoop dogg and martha
stewart and some other people this
t-shirt company uh in dallas that he's
like sold them too it's just like in our
culture with the weird adoration for dr
anthony fauci when they tried to like
make him like a like
pop cultural influence like it it's not
good i think part of it was like we lost
ruth bader ginsburg and so we needed
some other
like older new yorker that we all were
obsessed with and like they just
couldn't make anthony fouchy work
i don't know it just creeps remember
cuomo sexual
oh yeah that was wrong with these people
cultists
yeah all around man zilinski they
worship
the president of the united states they
worship him when he gets the job like
all of a sudden now he's something and
worship is a great word for it like it
has to be more than just like oh i
respect your work or he's got some good
points it's like weird devotion say what
they say do not question them like that
is these these are the icons that
they're trying to prop up for themselves
which is very
creepy it's creepy it's a creepy bunch
of people in a cult and they're all
voting so you better go out and tell all
your friends to go vote does nine life
sell devotional candles we've not gotten
into that market i think i might skip
that one
i mean unless i can use your face as a
model i feel like you're more jesusy
you have all the rights right adjectives
you just gave it out yeah it's all you
anyone that wants to make t-shirts with
my face on it they're all you make as
much money off of them as you want you
can make tens of dollars
you know the cult's getting bigger
um or maybe it's not i don't know what
do you guys think do you think i i feel
like you know liz cheney she's out we
got a primary tonight i think louder not
bigger
i think that sometimes with cults like
when they become stressed in some way
the people who are really devoted double
down and the people who are like on the
outside already sort of be like i don't
know if i want to leave and they back
out even now like i got employees that
work for me especially in leadership
then we don't always see the same
you know
same eye
and i know people voted for this and
whenever they're complaining about the
gas prices or not being able to hire
people or all of these things that you
voted for i i kindly remind them like
you did this like this is your fault and
they did exactly what they said they're
gonna do you know we had a previous
president said i'm going to build a wall
reduce energy prices do this do that
like he had a playbook and he went and
executed on not everything went
according to plan not everything went as
stated but that was his intention and he
went to work day one day one
they destroyed energy prices and energy
is tied to absolutely everything that we
have to deal with and transportation and
goods and you know it talk about
inflation it was day one how do we
create this
socialist society without going through
congress
and they did it you want 15 an hour no
problem because everything cost 15 now
so i got to pay someone who was being
paid 10 bucks to catch a t-shirt at the
end of the dryer is now being paid 15
now that manager who was 15 is now 20
and now everyone else is 25 and guess
what you only want to spend so much on a
usa made t-shirt right
but there is no incentive to buy things
in the u.s and there's no disincentive
to import stuff from china so when i
sell people that my competitors are
using slave cotton like literally slave
cotton and they're illegally putting
into their garments and then they're
selling it at a price point i can't
match because i don't have any slaves in
georgia that's hundreds of years ago and
freaking wrong well i gotta i gotta be
honest i'm pretty sure like this shirt
is probably like bangladesh or something
i can tell you that my stuff's not i
could tell you that there's no shirts
instead but there's a there's a price
point associated right so i want cheap
that's good and we're all done here in
the united states well that's not a
thing you can put your money where your
mouth is you can vote with your dollars
and that's what i've been trying to tell
people is that when you're sitting up on
stage and you're talking about all of
these values that you
are concerned about you know your social
justice warriors out there then why are
your products that you're wearing
literally made by slaves
why are the things that you're
purchasing going to regimes that hate us
and want to destroy us these are regimes
like the chinese communist government
not chinese people i have lots of
chinese friends so don't confuse the two
right the six percent ruling class of
china that rules with an iron fist that
has zero regard for human rights that
has zero regard for anything other than
world domination and i i don't care what
anyone else has to say that is what they
want you know this is an organization
that has said
recently that they've won the war
without firing a shot because they look
at economic warfare's warfare they look
at biological warfare as warfare so if
covid was not the perfect test run of
biological warfare and i'm not a
conspiracy theorist i'm just saying it
was a absolute biological agent that
wreaked havoc on the world except for
one
country which has seemed to benefit very
very much so you know we are living
blindly and we're putting our money and
we're voting
with our dollars towards organizations
that support china towards organizations
that support slavery and anyone who
wants to talk about that gets censored i
made a usa made shirt uh video today
talking about are cotton made in the u.s
are cutting and sewing me in the u.s are
printing in the u.s when now people are
out there saying hey you know you can't
make things the u.s like i can do it i'm
a freaking aviator i have zero knowledge
in textile manufacturing the last 10
years we've figured it out right we're
americans we can do this better cheaper
faster but no one cares so when the
president of the united states goes on
television and says during the state of
the union we're going to encourage and
make sure that everything's made in the
u.s not one piece of legislation is to
stop any type of imports of textile
goods that can be made here especially
from china not one piece of legislation
that gives credits towards
r d research and development for
manufacturing capabilities like ours
right so i can't get any type of credits
for my employees i hire i can't get any
credit for the r d that i do and i do a
lot of r d to be able to try to compete
with china i have to be more efficient
none of that if i was a tech company i
get lots of rd credits i paid no taxes
if i just took all my manufacturing and
i brought it overseas i'd make so much
more profit it's incredible and
apparently no one would care so until
the united states they're voting with
their dollars you know understand that
that money goes to an organization that
most likely
influences politics yeah we're just
going to keep it's simple doing more the
same china
can't er the chinese county's party
can't donate directly to a politician to
support them
but they can hire people to do things
who they know will support certain
politics thus giving more economic power
to people who will destroy this country
so we have no insight into china because
they have locked it down you can't
influence their politicians you'll go to
jail forever in that country do they
have politicians i just have party
members they do have party members but
you you're not influencing them you know
big brother is a thing you know we are
social your facial recognition you can't
leave cities without social credits i
mean it is 1984 today
and these organizations
china specifically the communist party
there's nothing that stops them from
espionage right coming here and learning
everything they can and bring it back to
their country i have intellectual
property that i sent to china to make
it's i have a hoodie that holds your b
or hands-free right so i've got two
patents one on an n95 mast so you can
breathe without dying it actually works
sorry fda said i can't say that
according to all of my fda tests it
works better than 3ms but i'm no longer
allowed to sell it because there's no
more euas and i just had to eat millions
of dollars really oh yeah absolutely wow
that's a whole different story but i
like science i like engineering so i
made this patented product where you can
hold your beer hands free on your hoodie
right not as like a socket or something
that's a cool pocket yes you kind of
dumbed down my patent but
yes it's a pocket in your in your hoodie
it's an engineering engineered
compartment thank you so much a kangaroo
pouch if you will um but i sent it to
china with the tech pack to have them
manufactured this is eight
years ago right
and they gave it to my competitors and
started selling everyone else and um
they told me that they don't believe in
intellectual property it's it's trade
secrets if it was if you can't own an
idea man there's no there's no patents
there they consider it trade secrets so
once the secret is known it can be
shared with absolutely everyone as long
as they can make money they will so
there is no
respect for intellectual property um
there is no respect for human life and
this is an organization that is not our
friend and they threaten to shoot down
our our uh what vice president secretary
defense sex state who is it that they
were going to shoot now
there we go speaker of the house so they
want to shoot down a sitting member of
uh congress and uh you know our response
is please don't do that you know we are
very weak country right now in my
opinion because we have weak leadership
and um
until that changes you know i i don't
see us
improving the midterms are coming up i'm
uh i'm pretty optimistic
i'm not super optimistic about the
leadership we're gonna end up with
mcconnell and you know kevin mccarthy so
nothing will really get done but you'll
have some good people in there doing
some good stuff it's not all bad right
yeah i think what we saw when you had uh
you know trump come to power you had a
change in politics that shook things up
you know it was a time when everyone was
tired with the status quo and they they
didn't want more of the same i think
people on both sides are starting to see
that again you know that going back to
traditional politicians you get more of
the same we actually
reversed course so fast day one
and to see the state of the economy
right now and to see the state of
affairs you know from a world stage
having traveled a lot into the eastern
european countries uh as of late you
know we are a joke
um yeah we're a laughingstock what do
you think about rhonda sanchez
i would be very excited for a uh
desantis ticket
if
our
current
i guess if the donald
were in my opinion to support and
endorse that person and push the trump
supporters
towards him i think that we actually
would have a shot you know conservatives
right i'll identify as a conservative
you know no other pronouns just
conservative and that's not a negative
thing it just means i'm a fiscal
conservative and social libertarian i
could care what you do with your
dingaling just don't talk to my children
about it that's my job
would you prefer trump or would you
prefer to santa's like if desantis
because i think he has
an opportunity to win because i think
there's more than this is nothing to do
with the donald right now i've gone to
mar-a-lago i've met him a few times i've
he's helped me with getting my friend
eddie gallagher out of prison you know i
i have no no ill will towards uh former
president united states what i do have
is uh it will towards not taking a uh a
stance towards what's the what's the
most likely course of action if he were
to run you're gonna have a lot of
individuals never trumpers that rally
their base to vote against him
just because it's him and that's the
unfortunate truth is that they'll get
more people that would have voted
conservative to not vote conservative
just because they don't like the orange
man
there um
there is a concerted effort in media
right now to go after tennis that way
you know they're actually trying to say
that he's worse than trump because they
have to they have to and it's crazy
because they already said trump was you
know literally worse than hitler and i'm
not entirely sure what they're
complaining about with desantis but they
have to say something
otherwise they'll win
that that's their play is they they just
say things louder and louder and louder
and you know my godfather i love having
a conversation with them i said break as
a thesaurus as bill buckley jr you kind
of started the modern conservative
movement and you know he would always
tell me that
you'll never win an argument with an
idiot they'll just talk louder and
that's what i find when i when i try to
engage into a political discussion with
someone who is so far left or honestly
right it really doesn't matter when you
have extremisms on both parties and you
can't
find a way to have a conversation
without raising your voice because we
have a different opinion on
women's reproductive rights about the
second amendment about that's all the
first amendment but it's i've seen it on
both sides too i've seen people go
extremely far
right and angry because i don't agree
with something to do with women's
reproductive rights right which i'm not
even going to get into that because it's
i just don't feel like it's a topic of
conversation where you can win it's just
a difference of opinion some people are
extremely religious some people are not
and i think that we've degraded
our our morals in this country and i
think that it's become the popular thing
not to go to church i think it's the
popular thing not to
have um
what i would consider old school
morals right that are usually
faith-based because it's not the cool
thing to do anymore and actually stalin
said it best that they'll never win a
war in the united states because of our
moral convictions because of the fact
that you know we believe in in our
country and what it's founded by and
that you can't break that spirit
and i think slowly but surely we've
eroded the morals of this country and
when i say morals i mean doing the right
thing when no one else is looking thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there